let me pick up on our caller from the
five-30 area code not calling today from
five five three zero are you there yes
I'm here hello David yes how are you I'm
doing well I was just just called in I
was wondering what you thought about
third parties affecting the election
this time I voted third party last time
and obviously that didn't go very well
and man your connection is not sounding
great am i the one with the bad
connection today very bad I can hear
everybody excellent and you sound like
you're talking through a tin can
I'm actually calling from a nuclear
submarine is this any better yes
actually a little bit you're now at the
end of a hallway but it sounds better
good well I actually am in a hallway so
that makes sense
listen third party okay so I'm I don't
believe that the two-party system best
serves our interests I think that you
know the Republican and Democratic Party
represent really a quite a narrow scope
of the political spectrum we would be
better served with a much wider scope of
representation I also believe that for
as long as we have the campaign finance
system we have and the
first-past-the-post voting system that
we have it's going to be extraordinarily
difficult for third parties to really
make headway and in the short term they
will potentially have the spoiler effect
that it sounds like you might be
referring to from 2016 yep totally
I'm calling from Northern California
sorry I didn't mention that that's okay
okay all right well I hope I answered
your question I appreciate the phone
call I do think we are finally getting
the phones working properly which is
exciting let's go to our next caller
from the nine seven eight area code
who's calling today from 9 7 8 and where
are you calling from hi my name is Isaac
I'm calling from NASA
this is just a phone number from Alabama
I believe love it okay I thought 978 was
Massachusetts but go ahead oh okay my
bad um so yeah here's my question how do
you feel about the current black lives
matter movement and do you think it will
lead to meaningful change and how do you
feel about how the movement currently
doesn't have like a current leader like
a face to lead the movement well listen
I I don't think it's my place to say
whether the movement should or shouldn't
have a face or a leader that's really up
i I don't even know to who because
there's no leader but I feel like it's
up to someone else to decide
I consider myself black lives matter
adjacent insofar as many of the goals of
black lives matter are the same goals
that I've been pushing for on this
program for a very long time my my
qualms with black lives matter as a
pseudo organization are on the record
that none of them I think will come as a
surprise to people since I've talked
about them before I believe that there
was at the time when the black lives
matter and women's march were sort of
overlapping I think they went in the
wrong direction from the standpoint of
having anti-semitic associated people
speaking for them and organizing events
I think that the way in which some black
lives matter chapters have thrown in
with the anti Israeli movement is
self-defeating and it's only going to
alienate what is really a natural
natural ally which is liberal American
Jews I think that they are going to be
alienated by some of the anti Israeli
language and stuff about you know the
fight for Palestine is the same thing
that that black look that you know we're
fighting for here against police
brutality etc you're starting to see
really wacky stuff come out like the
reason police are a problem in the u.s.
is because they got training from
Israeli officials on trips and you know
like really really crazy stuff so you
know for me
I don't really get too involved in the
in the groups and I've not even talked
about this for probably more than a year
but I'm glad you're bringing it up but I
am black lives matter adjacent in that I
support a lot of the ideas that I think
most of the people support that are part
of black lives matter great yeah I
believe like the entire sentiment is
very like I feel like the public broadly
approves of what the fear and sentiment
is for black lives matter yes but like I
feel like in the media it's people are
portraying them as you know X Y & Z and
I feel like that might like ruin the
reputation of the movement so I was just
hoping that we could just move forward
and talk about what really matters about
this matter well the thing is what
really matters to you or to me might be
different than what matters you know to
the people who are using black lives
matter to push Israeli BDS versus the
people who are using black lives matter
to say you know that what you know what
whatever I think the whole point is
there are things that will have
widespread agreement and then there are
areas where you you start to lose people
and I would focus on the lowest hanging
fruit that can achieve the most
meaningful change with the biggest
consensus okay great thank you so much
for your comments glad to be on your
show thank you so much thank you
appreciate the phone call great to hear
from you